that was really confrontational it was
really emotional nothing was left unsaid
you don't know what's going on between
us
Tom was combative Raquel didn't say much
off camera filming felt quote sad a
relief but so exhausting that's what a
source tells ET happened inside the near
eight hour taping I don't regret our
relationship
afterwards Tom and Raquel had a heart to
heart we're told they chatted over what
happened on set and how they felt it was
a rough day how rough quote Sandoval was
ultimately contrite but Raquel came
across like Sandoval loved her more than
Ariana I wish we both would have tried
harder you don't deserve one tear of
mine Ariana's take she stated her
feelings yesterday and now it's time to
untangle herself from Tom
castmates and friends were clearly team
Ariana they met up at a local bar and
reacted while watching our E.T coverage
of Scandal we're told Raquel Levis is
ready to apologize
and here's an update on Raquel's claim
that co-star Sheena Shea punched her can
you say the words You Got Served
yes Raquel had Andy Cohen deliver Sheena
this document ET exclusively obtained
titled request for dismissal it appears
to be about the temporary restraining
order but sheena's lawyer tells ET the
papers have no legal meaning this was
just another public relations stunt
today Raquel tells ET exclusively my
attorney is filing the appropriate
paperwork the temporary order was
intended to provide a cooling off period
after I was punched I will not be moving
forward with a permanent restraining
order
so what's next for the Vanderpump crew
season 11 hasn't been announced but
we're told in the next few weeks
producers will meet floating different
ideas to move forward either way both
Raquel and Tom's involvement on the show
is up in the air and Ariana has said
unless absolutely necessary she won't
film with Sandoval
[Music]